the harsh reality of the cost of living
crisis the engine in this is an old
diesel engine keith from nottingham puts
vegetable oil in his old land rover
because it's cheaper than diesel
we wouldn't be able to go out sort of we
put the dogs in the back of the land
rover and take them out for walks and
things again that would be something
that would be
not happen really keith's still working
but husband daryl is retired they're
former conservative voters but they're
not impressed by the two tory leadership
candidates whichever one of them you
listen to there's nothing that
i can think well yeah you're gonna help
me or else
just nothing i want us to be an
aspiration nation after declaring tax
cuts not handouts this weekend liz trust
now says she's not ruling out further
support for households
penny morden to dramatically endorse ms
trust at hustings after being narrowly
beaten by her in the voting by tory mps
says she's been misinterpreted she's not
ruled out all future help in fact part
of her
reason for her putting an emergency
budget forward is to really address some
of these issues but what she has i think
rightly challenged is the wisdom of
taking large sums of money out of
people's pockets in tax and then giving
some of it back in ever more complicated
ways
rishi sunak claims the country faces a
choice in the leadership campaign
between clear-eyed realism and
starry-eyed boosterism
and his supporters claim most trust has
now shifted on policy twice in a week on
regional pay and now cost of living help
i think it's a worrying sign of judgment
and it's quite clear the scale of what
we're going to face this autumn the kind
of increase in bills people are going to
face and merely bringing forward
national insurance cuts is not going to
help the most vulnerable people for
example if you're working full-time on
the national living wage it's worth less
than 60 pounds to you
earlier former labour chancellor and
prime minister gordon brown backed an
emergency budget and predicted a
financial time bomb in october it's
exactly a month since boris johnson
resigned as prime minister and voting
for his successor is now underway most
party members have received their ballot
paper it's accompanied by a letter from
the party's co-chairman andrew stevenson
saying both candidates would make an
excellent prime minister
but this weekend liz truss and rishi
sunak are further apart than ever on how
to tackle the cost of living crisis but
for daryl and keith the cost of living
crisis means they'll burn scraps of wood
they find that's firewood for the winter
because they can't afford central
heating john craig sky news